we are not taking off we're not caving
we're not moving we're not backing down
come to the table you need to give us
some attention speak to us about what's
going on and why we're here
um but i'm still
gonna sit here as long as it takes
and i don't know what mr trudeau is
thinking but we're holding the line just
lift up the mandate and we'll be out of
here just know that every trucker out
here we're willing to go to jail we're
willing to lose our trucks we're handed
out tickets today we'll just pay them
right nothing's gonna stop us from
accomplishing what we came here to do um
so
you know it's just a matter of time
until they realize that for us to leave
here is not an option unless
he is going to drop all the mandates and
set his people free
all the mandates in general gone done
done with open canada
right back up to normal the way it was
prior to lift all the mandates
and reside step down you're tired time
to leave it's not a matter of who's
going to win we've already won because
we've literally sparked that fire and no
matter what it's not going to go out
until we get our freedoms back it's time
to apologize
to resign
uh to drop all the mandates at least
meet with our people uh our leaders
show up in parliament he's not
he's he went into hiding
end of endings actually that's the other
day let's call it a day this virus has
done its thing there's all kinds of
signs it says it's over
just end the mandate the message is
clear
but they're not even
coming close to something everything
there's no communication or nothing
we're not giving up they're gonna stay
all the way
we're used to being out on the road for
weeks at a time so it's not facing us
one bit and with the amount of support
that we're getting from the locals and
literally people all over the world you
know we're just being encouraged more
and more every single day i'm tired of
the mandates i'm tired of all the
division that it's causing it's terrible
it's dividing families it's providing
people in general all across canada it's
no good